I should ask I'm not sure about this are
you a data scientist right that's a good
one no of course I'm not you know but
it's that's the thing you see you see
all these stats are thrown out there and
you you try to try to understand what's
being said
um but it's it's also very scary because
when you see these things that look very
legitimate and then they're they're
disproven or people say like you're
cherry picking like the dates and all
these other things it almost feels like
you can come to any conclusion that you
want to yeah and that's why I think this
is such a serious issue for the world of
Chess because
going forward if we don't take it
seriously now I think at some point
there is the potential for a much much
larger Scandal do you agree that like
with Magnus I think said that it is an
existential threat to chess like this is
a very serious problem that's only going
to get bigger because it's you're
basically
uh from a spectator perspective from a
competitor perspective or not sure that
you can trust any of the results
yeah I think that's for sure true when I
think back to the last like five to ten
years there are plenty of top level
tournaments that I played in where there
was no security at all yeah um you just
you just go into the auditorium and play
your games and that was that so I do
think it's a big issue I think it has
been a big issue but the reason it's
only coming to light now is because it
features a very strong Junior player
who's very close to the world's Elite
there have been many cheating scandals
before uh there was this French player
Sebastian Fowler there was this player
Igor's Rouses from Latvia
um there was this uh I think it's from
Belarus or maybe maybe I have that wrong
it was Bulgaria borislav Ivanov as well
those are three big cheating scandals
but they were not at the absolute top
levels of Chess which I think is why
um it never became the huge news story
that this is or it wasn't viewed in the
same kind of ways why I think organizers
were perhaps a little bit too LAX in
terms of security so you said
2650 is it possible
that Hans is in fact a kind of Bobby
Fischer level of genius and he's capable
at times of Genius at the chessboard oh
absolutely 100 that that is absolutely
possible I think that's why I think for
everybody in the situation we want to
see what happens in the next six to 12
months because I think it will be very
clear also it's very interesting to me
because there are other stats um from
that 72-page report that chess.com
compiled which in essence says certain
other Junior players basically have
peaked that they're not likely to
improve further so it's also going to be
very interesting when you look at those
like I think it was like 50 pages of
graphs because there are graphs that say
like some of the other Junior players
are done so when we look forward like in
a year or two if those players don't
improve it will also say something about
their methods as well that they've used
to sort of compile this data
yeah I wonder what those Junior players
do if they look at that data so there's
a point where you should look at
yourself like practically
like what what is the actual empirical
data over the past year of how much I've
improved at a particular thing like it's
one thing to kind of tell yourself that
these are the ways I need to improve and
it's another to actually look at the
data and face the reality of it right I
I think also that could have a
psychological effect that is the other
thing that makes the whole Han situation
so tough because if you think that he's
cheated or you're unsure about what's
going on that is another psychological
Factor whenever you play against it in
his favor or against a favor definitely
in his favor because for example if I go
online and play against the computer
let's just say I go play against sawfish
tomorrow I'm going to play a very
certain type of opening strategy try to
keep the board closed and maybe hope to
get lucky now computers have gotten so
good that generally even that doesn't I
don't even have a chance even with such
strategies but you play differently than
you normally would and so if you're
playing a game against him and there's a
move that looks really weird
um it doesn't seem logical at all that
can also start to affect you where you
immediately make a mistake or you start
questioning yourself you start thinking
well what's going on here is there
something
um something Unbecoming like you start
worrying about what is happening and so
it definitely is uh it is it's a very
tough situation